The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseware
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseware
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR ERIC
GRIMSON: All right, I'm
going to start today
by talking about,
so what have we been doing?
What have we actually done
over the last few lectures?
And I want to suggest
that what we've done
is, we've outlined a lot of the
basic elements of programming.
A lot of the basic
elements we're
going to need to write code.
And I want to just highlight
it for you because we're going
to come back and look at it.
So I'm going to
suggest that we've
looked at three different
kinds of things.
We've talked about data,
we've talked about operations,
and we've talked about
commands or statements.
All right?
Data's what we expect.
It's our way of
representing fundamentally
the kinds of information
we want to move around.
And here, I'm going to
suggest we've seen numbers,
we've seen strings,
and I'm going
to add Booleans here as well.
They're a third kind
of value that we
saw when we started
talking about conditions.
We saw, associated with
that primitive data,
we have ways of taking
data in and creating
new kinds of data out, or
new versions of data out,
so we have operations.
Things like addition
and multiplication,
which we saw not only
apply to numbers,
but we can use them
on things like strings
and we're going to come
back to them again.
Can't use them on Booleans, they
have a different set of things.
They do things like AND, and OR.
And of course there's a
bunch of other ones in there,
I'm not going to
put them all up,
but we're building up a little
collection, if you like,
of those operations.
And then the main
thing we've done
is, we've talked about commands.
So I'm going to suggest we've
seen now four different things.
We've seen assignment, how
to bind a name to a value.
We've seen input and output.
Print for output, for example,
and raw input for input.
We've seen conditionals, or
said another way, branches,
ways of changing
the flow of control
through that sequence of
instructions we're building up.
And the last thing we
added were loop mechanisms.
And here we saw, while.
It's the first
example we've seen.
So what've we done so far?
Now, interestingly,
this set of instructions
was actually quite
powerful, and we're
going to come back to
that later on, in terms
of what we can do with it,
but what we've really done
is, given that basis,
we're now talking about,
how do we write common
patterns of code,
how do we write
things that solve
particular kinds of problems.
So what I want you to do,
is to keep in mind, those
are the bases, we
ought to be able to do
a lot with that bases, but
what we're really interested in
is not filling out a whole
bunch of other things in here,
but how do we put them
together into common templates.
And we're going
to do that today.
Second thing we've
been doing, I want
to highlight for you is, we've
along the way, mostly just
verbally rather than
writing it down,
but we've been talking
about good style.
Good programming style.
All right?
Things that we
ought to do, as you
put these pieces
together, in order
to give you really good code.
And you should be
collecting those together.
Give you some examples.
What have we talked about?
We've talked about things
like using comments
to highlight what you're
doing in the code,
to make it easier to debug.
We talked about type
discipline, the notion
that you should check
the types of operands
before you apply operators to
them, to make sure that they're
what the code is expecting.
We talked about descriptive
use of good variable names,
as a way, in essence, of
documenting your code.
The fourth one we talked
about was this idea
of testing all possible branches
through a piece of code,
if it's got conditionals
in it, to make sure
that every possible
input is going
to give you an output that
you actually want to see.
So, you know, you can start
writing your own, kind of,
Miss Manners book,
if you like, I mean,
are what are good
programming, you
know-- I wonder what
you'd call them,
John, good programming hygiene?
Good programming style?
Good programming
practices?-- Things that you
want to do to write good code.
OK.
What we're going to
do today is, we're
going to start now building
up, beyond just these pieces,
although they're valuable, to
start creating two things: one,
common patterns of
code that tackle
certain classes of
problems, and secondly we're
going to talk about tools you
can use to help understand
those pieces of things.
OK.
So last time around, we talked
about, or introduced if you
like, iterative programs.
And I want to generalize
that for a second,
because we're going to come
back and use this a lot.
And I want to do a very
high-level description
of what goes into an
iterative program,
or how I would think
about this, all right?
And I know if John disagrees
with me he'll tell me,
but this is my way
of thinking about it.
If I want to try and
decide how to tackle
a problem in an iterative
matter, here the steps
I'm going to go through.
First thing I'm
going to do, is I'm
going to choose a variable
that's going to count.
What I meant-- what in the
world do I mean by that?
I'm thinking about
a problem, I'm
going to show you an example
in a second, first thing I'm
going to do is say,
what is the thing that's
going to change every time I run
through the same set of code?
What is counting my way
through this process?
Now I'm putting count
in double quotes,
not to make it a string, but to
say, this is count generically.
It could be counting one by
one through the integers,
it could also be taking
a collection of data
and going through
them one by one.
It could be doing counting
in some other mechanism.
But what's the
variable I want to use?
Second thing I do, I
need to initialize it.
And I need to initialize
it outside of the loop.
That is, where do
I want to start?
And I need to make sure I have
a command that sets that up.
The third thing
I'm going to do, is
I need to set up
the right end test.
How do I know when I'm
done with the loop?
And obviously, that
ought to involve
the variable in some
way, or it's not
going to make a lot of sense,
so this includes the variable,
since that's the
thing that's changing.
All right.
The fourth thing
I'm going to do,
is I'm going to then
construct the block of code.
And I want to remind
you, that block of code
is a set of instructions,
the same set of instructions
that are going to be done
each time through the loop.
All that's going to change,
is the value the variable
or the value of some
data structures.
And remind you that
inside of here,
I'd better be
changing the variable.
All right, if that variable
that's counting is not
changing, I'm going to be
stuck in an infinite loop,
so I ought to
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] that ,
right, expect
somewhere in there,
a change of that variable.
All right?
And then the last
thing I want to do,
is just decide, you know,
what do I do when I'm done.
OK.
I know.
It looks boring.
But it's a structure
of the things
I want to think about
when I go through trying
to take a problem and mapping
it into a iterative program.
Those are the things I
want to see if I go along.
All right.
So let me give you an example.
I'm given an integer
that's a perfect square,
and I want to write a little
piece of code that's going
to find the square root of it.
All right, so I'm
cheating a little,
I know it's a perfect
square, somebody's
given it to me, we'll come back
in a second to generalizing it,
so what would the steps be that
I'd use to walk through it?
Well if you think
about these steps,
here's an easy way to do it.
Let's start at 1.
Let's call x the
thing I'm trying
to find the square root of.
Let's start at 1.
Square it.
If it's not greater
than x, take 2.
Square it.
If it's not greater
than x, take 3.
Square it.
And keep going, until the
square of one of those integers
is greater than or equal to--
sorry, just greater than x.
OK, why am I doing that?
When I get greater than x,
I've gone past the place
where I want to be.
And obviously, when
I get to something
whose square is equal to x,
I've got the answer I want,
and I kick it out.
So who knows what I've done?
I've identified the thing
I'm going to use to count,
something some variable is going
to just count the integers,
I've identified
the end test, which
is when that square is bigger
than the thing I'm looking
for, I've identified
basically what I want
to do inside the
loop, which is simply
keep changing that
variable, and I
didn't say what I want
to do when I'm done,
essentially print
out the answer.
OK, so how can I code this up?
Well, you might think,
let's just jump in
and write some code, I don't
want to quite do that though,
because I want to show
you another tool that's
valuable for thinking about
how to structure the code,
and that is a something
called a flow chart.
Now.
People of Professor
Guttag's and my age,
unfortunately remember flow
charts back-- as they say,
on the Simpsons, back in the
day, back in the 1960's, John,
right?-- really good programmers
had these wonderful little
plastic stencils, I
tried to find one,
I couldn't find it It's a little
stencil with little cut-out
shapes on it, that you
used to draw flow charts,
I'm going to show
you in a second,
and you tucked it right in here
next to your pocket protector
with all your pens
in it, you know,
so, your belt was
also about this high,
and your glasses were
this thick, you know,
we have a few of
those nerds left,
we mostly keep
them in the museum,
but that was what you
did with the flow chart.
Despite making a
bad joke about it,
we're going to do
the same thing here.
We're going to do
the same thing here,
we're going to chart
out a little bit of what
should go into actually
making this thing work.
So here's a simple
flow chart that I'm
going to use to capture
what I just described.
And I'm going to,
again, I'm actually
going to do it the way they
used to do it, and draw
a rectangle with
rounded corners, that's
my starting point, and
then what did I say to do?
I said I need to
identify a variable,
I'm going to give it a
name, let's just call ANS,
for answer, and I
need to initialize it,
so I'm going to come
down, and in a square box,
I'm going to
initialize ANS to 0.
And now I want to
run through the loop.
What's the first
thing I do in a loop?
I test an end test.
So the flow chart says,
and the tradition was
to do this in a
diamond shape, I'm
going to check if
ANS times ANS-- oh,
which way did I want to
do this-- is less than
or equal to x.
Now that's a test.
There are two possibilities.
If the answer is yes, then I'm
still looking for the answer,
what do I want to do?
Well, I don't have
to do anything other
than change the counter.
So I'm going to go
to ANS is ANS plus 1,
and I'm going to do it again.
Eventually, if I've done
this right, that test is no--
and I wonderfully ran out of
room here-- in which case,
I'm going to go to a print
statement, which was always
done in a trapezoid,
and print out ANS.
I should have put a box
below it that says stop.
OK?
While.
And notice what I got here.
Actually, this is a useful
tool for visualizing
how I'm trying to
put it together,
because it lets me
see where the loop is,
right there, it lets
me see the end test,
it lets me make sure that I'm in
fact initializing the variable
and I'm checking the right
things as I go along.
And the idea of this flow chart
is, if you start, you know,
a little ball bearing here, it's
going to roll down, setting up
an assignment statement,
and then, depending on here,
it's like there's a pair
of flippers in there,
it does the test, it
sets the ball this way
to change it to ANS plus
1, and comes back around,
eventually it's going to
drop through and print out
the answer.
The reason I'm going to
show you this flow chart,
I'm going to do one other
example in a second,
but I want to show
you a comparison.
Remember last time, we wrote
this simple piece of code
to print out even or odd.
If, you know, x, it was
in fact, even or odd.
So let me show you
what a flow chart
for that would look like,
because I want to make
a comparison point here.
If I were to do a flow chart for
that one, I'd do the following.
It reminds you,
that the test here
was, we took x if that's
what we were looking for,
it did integer division
by 2, multiplied it by 2,
and we check to see if
that was the same as x.
If the answer is yes, then
we did a print of even.
If the answer was no,
we did a print of odd,
and we then carried on.
Again, while.
But there's an
important point here.
Remember last time,
I said that there's
different kinds of
complexity in our code,
and I suggested for simple
branching programs, the amount
of time it takes
to run that program
is, in essence, bounded by
the number of instructions,
because you only execute each
instruction at most once.
It didn't depend on
the size of the input.
And you can see that there.
I start off, either I take
this path and carry on,
or I take that path and carry
on, but each box, if you like,
gets touched exactly once.
On the other hand,
look at this one.
This depends now
on the size of x.
All right?
Because what am I going to do?
I'm going to come down and
say, is ANS squared less than
or equal to x?
If it is, I'm going to
go around, and execute
that statement, check it again,
and go around and execute that.
So I'm going to cycle
around that loop there
enough times to
get to the answer,
and that number of times is
going to depend on the input,
so as I change the
input, I'm going
to change the
complexity of the code.
Now this happens to be what we
would call a linear process,
because the number of
times I go around the loop
is directly related to
the size of the argument.
If I double the
argument, I'm going
to double the number of
times I go around the loop.
If I increase it
by five, I'm going
to increase by five the number
of times I go around the loop.
We'll see later on, there
are classes of computation
that are inherently
much more complex.
We hate them, because
they're costly,
but they're sometimes
inherently that way.
But you can see the
comparison between these two.
OK.
Now, having done that,
let's build this code.
Yeah, if my machine will
come back up, there we go.
So, I'm going to now
go ahead and write
a little piece of
code, and I put it here
and I hope you can actually
see these better this time,
let me uncomment that region.
All right.
So, there's basically an
encapsulation of that code,
right?
It says-- what, look
at this, where am I,
right here-- I've got some
value for x initially,
I'm going to set ANS
to 0, just like there,
and there's my loop, there's the
test, which is right like that,
is ANS squared less
than or equal to x,
if it is, there's the block
corresponding to the loop,
change ANS, and eventually when
I'm done with all this thing,
I'm just going to print ANS out.
OK.
All right, let me show you one
other tool that I want to use.
Which is, I've written
that piece of code,
I ought to check it.
Well, I could just run it,
but another useful thing to do
is, I'm, especially as I
want to debug these things,
is to simulate that code.
And I'm going to do this
because, as Professor
Guttag noticed to me, students
seem reluctant to do this.
I guess it's not
macho enough, John,
to just, you know, you know,
go off and do things by hand,
you ought to just run them,
but it's a valuable tool
to get into, so let
me do that here.
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
I'm doing such a great job.
I've got to say, when my, I've
got two sons, now aged eighteen
and twenty, they
used to think I had
the coolest job in
the world because I
came home covered in chalk.
Now they have a different
opinion that you can probably
figure out.
All right.
Simulate the code.
What I mean by that is,
pick a simple set of values,
and let's walk through
it to see what happens.
And this is useful
because it's going
to allow me to A, make sure
that I've got something that's
going to terminate,
it's going to let
me make sure that
in fact I'm doing
the right kinds of updates.
I could do this, by the
way, by running the code
and putting print statements
in various places as well,
but the hand
simulation is valuable,
so let me just start it.
What do I have here?
I need the variable,
ANS, I need x,
and I need ANS times
ANS, ANS times ANS.
Right.
Those are the three
things that are
involved in this
computation. and I pick
something reasonably simple.
The ANS starts at 0.
I set up x, I think,
to be 16 there.
So what does the loop say?
I can either look
at my flow chart,
or I can look at the code.
If I look at the flow chart,
it says, I'm at this point.
Look at ANS squared.
Is it less than or
equal to-- sorry,
first of all, ANS squared is 0,
is it less than or equal to x,
yes.
So what do I do?
Change ANS.
X doesn't change.
Back around to the test.
What's ANS squared?
It's 1.
Is it less than or equal to 16?
Sure.
Run the loop again.
ANS becomes 2.
X stays 16.
ANS squared is 4.
Is that less than
or equal to 16?
Yes.
Aren't you glad I didn't
pick x equals 500?
All right.
ANS goes up by 0.
ANS squared is nine.
Still less than or equal to 16.
ANS goes to 4.
X stays the same.
4 squared is 16.
Is 16 less than or equal to 16?
Yes.
So ANS goes to five.
ANS squared becomes 25.
Ah!
That is now no longer true
here, so I print out 5.
Right.
Sure.
Square root of 16 is 5.
It's Bush economics.
OK?
I know.
I'm not supposed to make
bad jokes like that.
What happened?
Yeah.
STUDENT: It doesn't
stop at the right place.
PROFESSOR ERIC
GRIMSON: It doesn't
stop at the right place.
Thank you.
Exactly.
Right?
My bug here is right there.
Ah, let me find my cursor.
I probably want that.
Right?
I want less than, rather
than less than or equal to.
This is an easy bug
to come up with.
But imagine, if you
don't do the test,
you're going to get answers
that don't make any sense.
And in fact, if we just
go ahead and run this now,
hopefully we get
out-- oops, sorry,
I'm going to have to
change this quickly,
I still have some
things uncommented
at the bottom, yeah,
there they are,
I don't think we
need that yet, all
right, we will
comment those out.
OK.
So.
Why did I do it?
It's a simple example, I agree,
but notice what I just did.
It allowed me to highlight, is
the code doing the right thing?
I spotted an error here,
I could have spotted it
by running it on different test
sets, and using prints things,
another way of doing
it, but this idea
of at least simulating
it on simple examples
lets you check a couple
of important questions.
And in fact, now let me
ask those two questions
about this piece of code.
First question is, for
what values of integers--
we're going to assume integers--
but for what values of x
does this code terminate?
And the second question
is, for what values of x
does it give me back
the right answer?
All right, first question.
What values of x
does it terminate?
Again, assume x is an integer.
Well, break it down into pieces.
Suppose x is positive.
Does it terminate?
Sure.
All right?
Because ANS starts out
as 0, so ANS squared is
0, and each time through
the loop, ANS is increasing.
That means, at some point, in
some finite number of steps,
ANS squared has got to get
bigger than x if x is positive.
So for positive
integers, it terminates.
And it probably, I
think we can deduce,
returns the right answer here.
Right.
X is negative.
X is -16.
Does this code terminate?
Boy, I feel like
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Does this terminate?
Somebody.
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC
GRIMSON: Ah, thank you,
so it does terminate, right?
You're sitting too far back, let
me try-- oh, too far!-- Sorry.
Come get me one later
if you can't find it.
Yes, it stops at the
first step, right?
Let's look at it.
It says, if answer, sorry,
imagine x is -16, ANS is 0,
is 0 less than -16, no.
So what does it do?
It prints out 0.
Ah!
So that now answers my second
question, it does terminate,
but does it give me
the right answer?
No.
Right?
It gives me an
answer, and imagine
I'm using this somewhere else,
you know, it's going to go off
and say, gee, the
square root of -16 is 0.
Well, it really should be a,
you know, an imaginary number,
but this is not a valuable
thing to have come back.
So that's the second thing
I've just highlighted here,
is that I now have the
ability to check whether it
does the right thing.
And those are two
things that you'd
like to do with every
looping construct you write:
you'd like to be able to assure
yourself that they will always
terminate, and then the
second thing you'd like to do,
is to assure yourself
that it does give you back
a reasonable answer.
We started to talk about
ways to do the former.
It's looking at the end test.
It's looking at the
kinds of conditions
you're going to put in.
For the latter, this
is a place where
running test cases would do a
good job of helping with that.
Nonetheless, having done that,
let's look at a better way
to write this.
Which is right here, it is
also, I think, on your sheet,
I'm going to uncomment that,
and comment this one out, yeah.
All right?
So let's look at this
code for a second.
Notice what this does.
Certainly the heart
of it, right in here,
is still the same thing.
But notice what this does.
The first thing it does
is, it says, let's check
and make sure x is greater
than or equal to 0.
If it isn't, notice
what's going to happen.
None of that block is
going to get executed,
and it's going to come
down here and print out
a useful piece of
information, which says, hey,
you gave me a negative number.
I don't know how to do this.
If it is, in fact, positive,
then we're going to go in here,
but now notice what
we're doing here.
There is the basic thing
we did before, right?
We're checking the end
test and incrementing,
actually I was going to, I
commented that out for a reason
you'll see in a second,
but I, normally I
would keep this on, which
would let me, at each step,
see what it's doing.
If I ran this, it would
print out each step.
Which is helping me
make sure that it's
incrementing the right way.
OK, once it gets to the end of
that, what's it going to do?
It's going to come
down here and, oh.
What's that doing?
Well, I cheated when I started.
I said, somebody's giving
me a perfect square,
I'm looking for the
square root of it.
But suppose I gave this thing
15, and asked it to run.
It'd still give me an answer.
It just would not be the
answer I'm looking for.
So now, in this case, this code
is going to, when we get here,
check, and if you haven't
seen that strange thing there,
that exclamation point in
computer-ese called a bang,
it says if ANS star ANS is
not equal to x, all right?
What's that say, it
says, I've already
gotten to the end
of the loop, I'm now
past where I wanted
to be, and I'm
going to check to make sure
that, in fact, this really
is a perfect square.
If it isn't, print
out something says,
ah, you gave me something
that wasn't a perfect square.
And only if that is true, am I
going to print out the answer.
It's the same computation.
But this is a nice
way of writing it,
often called
defensive programming.
And I think we have lots of
variations on it-- I don't
know about John, what
your favorite is,
for the definition of defensive
programming-- for me it says,
make sure that I'm going
through all possible paths
through the code, make sure
I'm printing out, or returning
if you like, useful information
for each style, sorry,
for each path through
the code, make sure
that for all
possible inputs there
is a path through
the code, or a way
to get through the code,
that does not cause an error
or infinite loop.
What else would you add, John?
PROFESSOR JOHN
GUTTAG: Well, we'll
come back to this
later in the term,
and talk in some detail
about particular techniques.
The basic idea of
defensive programming
is, to assume that A, if you're
getting inputs from a user,
they won't necessarily give
you the input you've asked for,
so if you ask for
a positive number,
don't count on them
giving you one, and B,
if you're using a piece
of a program written
by a programmer
who is not perfect,
perhaps yourself, there could
be mistakes in that program,
and so you write your program
under the assumption that,
not only might the
user make a mistake,
other parts of your program
might make a mistake,
and you just put in
lots of different tests
under the assumption
that you'd rather catch
that something has gone wrong,
then have it go wrong
and not know it.
And we'll talk later in
the term about dozens
of different tricks, but the
main thing to keep in mind
is the general principle
that people are dumb.
And will make mistakes.
And therefore, you
write your programs
so that catastrophes don't occur
when those mistakes are made.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Good.
As John said, we're
going to come back to it.
But that's what,
basically the goal here.
And you saw me put my hands up
when I said stupid programmer?
I've certainly written
code that has this problem,
I've tried to use my own
and good to us,
right, good hygiene,
I'm going to use
that word again here,
of getting into the habit
of writing defensive code up
front, it's part of that
collection of things
that you ought to do,
is a great thing to do.
I stress it in
particular because, I
know you're all going
to get into this stage;
you've got a problem set
due in a couple of hours,
you're still writing the code,
you don't want to waste time,
and I'm going to use quotes
on "waste time", doing those
extra things to do the
defensive programming,
you just want to get
the darn thing done.
It's a bad habit to get into,
because when you come back
to it, it may haunt you
later on down the road.
So really get into
that notion of trying
to be defensive as you program.
OK.
The other thing I
want to say here,
is that this style of
program we just wrote,
is actually a very common one.
And we're going to give it
a nice little name, often
referred to as
exhaustive enumeration.
What does that mean?
It says, I'm literally walking
through all possible values
of some parameter, some
element of the computation,
testing everything until
I find the right answer.
All right, so it's,
you know, again, I
can even write that
down, essentially saying,
try all reasonable values
until you find the solution.
And you might say,
well, wait a minute,
isn't that going to
be really expensive?
And the answer is, yeah, I
guess, if you want to search,
you know, all the pages
on Google, one by one,
yes, probably, it's
going to take a while.
But there are an awful lot of
computations for which this
is the right way to do it.
You just want to exhaustively
go through things.
And just to give
you a sense of that,
let me show you an example.
I'm going to change
this, all right?
Nice big number.
You know, computers
are fast these days.
I can make this
even bigger, it's
going to do it fairly
quickly, so it really
is quick to do this.
It doesn't mean that exhaustive
enumeration is a bad idea,
it is often the
right idea to use.
So we've seen one
example of this,
this idea of walking through
all the integers looking
for the square root.
Let's look at some
other examples,
in order to try and see other
ways in which we could do it.
OK.
In particular, let's
go over to here,
and let me show you
a second example.
And let me comment that out.
Here's another problem
that I'd like to solve.
Suppose I want to find all
the divisors of some integer,
I want to figure out
what all the divisors are
that go evenly into it.
Again, same kind of reasoning
says, given some value
x, I happened to pick a small
one here, what's an easy way
to do this?
Well, let's just start at one.
That's my variable I'm
going to change and check.
Does it divide evenly into x?
If it does, print it out.
Move on to the next
one, print it out.
So again, I can do the
same kind of thing here,
you can see that,
in fact, let's just
run it to make sure it
does the right thing, OK?
In fact, if I go
back to the code,
what did I decide to do here?
I say, starting with
an initialization of I,
there's my first
step, as equal to 1,
I'm going to walk
through a little loop
where I check, as
long-- first of all,
as long as I is less than
x, so there's my end test,
I'm going to do something.
And in this case,
the something is,
I'm going to look to see
if I divides x evenly.
So I'll remind you
of that amp-- sorry,
that percent sign there,
that says if x divided by I
has a 0 remainder, because this
gives me back the remainder,
if that's equal to 0,
print something out.
And there's my nice increment.
Simple little piece of code.
Notice again, exactly
the same form:
I picked the thing
I wanted to vary,
I initialized it
outside the loop,
I have a test to
see when I'm done,
and then I've got a
set of instructions
I'm doing every time
inside the loop.
In this case, it's doing
the check on the remainder
and printing them out.
And when I'm done
with the whole thing,
before I end the
increment of the variable,
you know, when I'm done, I'm
just not returning anything
out.
OK.
So now you've seen
two simple examples.
Let me generalize this.
In this case, my incrementer
was just adding 1 to an integer,
it's a pretty
straightforward thing to do.
But you can imagine
thinking about this a little
differently.
If I somehow had a collection,
an ordered collection of all
the integers, from
1 to 10, I could
imagine doing the same thing,
where now what I'm doing
is, I'm starting with the first
element of that collection,
doing something, going
to the next element,
doing something, going to the
next element, doing something,
I'm just walking through
the sequence of elements.
Right?
And I haven't said yet, how
do I get that collection,
but you could
certainly conceptualize
that, if I had that collection,
that would be nice thing to do.
That is a more common pattern.
That is basically saying,
given some collection of data,
I want to have again a
looping mechanism, where
now my process is, walk
through this, the collection,
one element at a time.
And for that, we have
a particular construct,
called a FOR loop.
It's going to do
exactly that for us.
It's going to be more
general than this,
and we're going to
come back to that,
in fact, Professor Guttag's
going to pick this up
in a couple of lectures,
but we can talk right now
about the basic form.
The form of a FOR
loop says, FOR,
and I'm going to put
little angle braces in here
again, to say,
for some variable,
like a name I want to get
to it, in some collection,
and then I have a block of code.
And what it's saying
semantically is,
using that variable
as my placeholder,
have it walk through
this collection,
starting at the first thing,
execute that code, then
the next thing, execute
that code, and so on.
One of the advantages
of this is,
that I don't have to
worry about explicitly
updating my variable.
That happens for
me automatically.
And that's very
nice, because this
allows me to be sure that my
FOR loop is going to terminate.
And because, as long as
this collection is finite,
this thing is just
going to walk through.
All right?
So, if I show you,
for example, I'm
going to comment this one
out in the usual manner,
and let's look at
uncommenting that, there
is the same piece of code.
Now, I slung something by
you, or snuck something
by you, which is,
I hadn't said how
to generate the set of
integers from 1 to 10.
So, range is a built-in
Python function.
I'm going to come back
to it in a second.
For now, just think
of it as saying, it
gives you all the integers from
1 up to, but not including, x.
OK.
But now you can see the form.
This now says, OK, let I start
as the first thing in there,
which is 1, and then do
exactly as I did before,
the same thing, but
notice I don't need
to say how to increment it.
It's happening
automatically for me.
OK.
In fact, if I run it,
it does the same thing,
which is what I would expect.
OK.
Now, the advantage of the FOR,
as I said, is that it has,
then, if you like, a
cleaner way of reading it.
I don't have to worry
about, do I initialize it,
did I forget to initialize
it outside the loop,
it happens automatically
just by the syntax of it,
right there, that's going to
start with the first element.
I don't have to
worry about, did I
remember to put
the incrementer in,
it's going to automatically
walk it's way through there.
Second advantage of the FOR
is, that right now, we're
thinking about it just as
a sequence of integers.
We could imagine it's just
counting its way through.
But we're going to
see, very shortly,
that in fact those collections
could be arbitrary.
We're going to have other
ways of building them,
but it could be a collection
of all the primes.
Hm.
There's an interesting
thing to do.
It could be a collection of,
ah, you know, I don't know,
batting averages of
somebody or other.
It could be
arbitrary collections
that you've come up
with in other ways.
The FOR is, again, going to let
you walk through that thing.
So it does not have
to be something
that could be described
procedurally, such as add 1
just to the previous element.
It could be any
arbitrary collection.
And if I were to
use that again, I'd
just put it on your
handout, I could go back
and rewrite that thing
that I had previously
for finding the square roots
of the perfect squares,
just using the FOR loop.
OK.
What I want to do, though,
is go on to-- or, sorry,
go back to-- my divisor example.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] OK.
Try again.
I've got a number, I want
to find the divisors.
Right now, what my
code is doing is,
it's printing them up
for me, which is useful.
But imagine I actually wanted
to gather them together.
I wanted to collect them, so I
could do something with them.
I might want to add them up.
Might want to multiply
them together.
Might want to do, I don't
know, something else with them,
find common divisors, of
things by looking at them.
I need, in fact, a
way to make explicit,
what I can't do
that with range, is
I need a way to collect
things together.
And that's going to be the
first of our more compound data
structures, and we have
exactly such a structure,
and it's called a tuple.
This is an ordered
sequence of elements.
Now, I'm going to
actually add something
to it that's going to make
sense in a little while,
or in a couple of lectures,
which is, it is immutable.
Meaning, I cannot change it, and
we'll see why that's important
later on.
But for now, tuple is this
ordered sequence of structures.
OK.
And how do I create them?
Well, the representation is,
following a square bracket,
followed by a sequence of
elements, separated by commas,
followed by a closed
square bracket.
And that is literally
what I said,
it is an ordered
sequence of elements,
you can see where they are.
OK?
So, let me do a little
example of this.
If I go back over here,
let's define-- er,
can't type-- I can look
at the value of test,
it's an ordered sequence.
I need to get
elements out of it.
So again, I have a
way of doing that.
In particular, I can ask for
the zeroth element of test.
OK, notice, I'm putting a
square bracket around it,
and it gives me-- I know
this sounds confusing,
but this is a long tradition,
it gives me-- ah, yes.
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Sorry?
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
I created a list here?
Ah, thank you.
I'm glad you guys
are on top of it.
You're saying I want that.
Is that right, John?
Yes?
OK.
Sorry.
You're going to see why this
was a mistake in a little while.
I did not want to
make a list, I wanted
to create a tuple thank
you for catching it.
I want parens, not
square brackets there.
You'll also see in a little
while why both of these things
would work this way, but
it's not what I wanted.
OK?
So I guess I should
go back, and let
me do this correctly this way.
Again, I can look at
test, and I guess test now
if I want to get the
element out-- angle
bracket or square bracket?
I still want square bracket,
that's what I thought-- OK.
Now I can go back
to where I was,
which is a strange
piece of history, which
is, we start counting at 0.
So the-- I hate to
say it this way,
the first element of this tuple
is at position 0, or index 0,
OK?-- so I can get the zeroth
one out, I can get, if I do 2,
I get the third thing out,
because it goes 0, 1, 2--
notice, however, if I do
something that tries to go
outside the length of the tuple
it complains, which is right.
Tuples? also have
another nice structure,
which is, I can go the
other direction, which
is, if I want to get the
last element of that tuple
I give it a negative index.
So, imagine, you think of it
as, is it starting right, just
before the beginning
of the thing,
if I give it a 0 it's going
to take the first one,
if I give it a 1, it's
going to take the next one,
but I can go the other
direction, if I give it a -1,
it picks up the last
element of the tuple.
And again, I can go -2, go back.
So this is what we
would call selection.
We can do things like
foo of 0 to get out
the particular element.
I can also pick up
pieces of that tuple.
Again I want to show
you the format here.
If I give it this
strange expression,
this is saying I want to
get the piece of the tuple
starting at index 1, it's
going to be the second element,
and going up to but
not including index 3.
And it gives me back that piece.
Actually a copy of that
piece of the tuple.
This is called slicing.
And then just to complete this.
Two other nice things you
can do with slices are you
can get the beginning
or the end of tuple.
So, for example, if I say TEST
and I don't give it a start
but I give it an end, then
it gives me all the elements
up to that point.
And I can obviously
do the other direction
which is I can say skip to index
2 and all the remaining pieces.
This lets me slice
out, if you like,
the front part or back part or
a middle part of the tuple as I
go along.
What in the world does that have
to do with my divisor example?
Well, actually, before I do that
let me in fact fill in a piece
here.
Which is remember I said range
we could think of conceptually
as a tuple -- or sorry as
a sequence of these things.
In fact it gives me
back, now I hate this,
it's actually a list
it's not a tuple.
But for now think
of it as giving you
back an explicit version of
that representation of all
those elements.
You'll see why I'm going
to make that distinction
in a couple of lectures.
All right.
What does this have to do
with my divisor example?
This says I can make tuples,
but imagine now going back
to my divisor example
and I want to gather up
the elements as I go along.
I ought to be able to do
that by in fact just adding
the pieces in.
And that's what I'm
going to do over here.
Which is, let me comment that
out, let me uncomment that.
And I guess I need the
same thing here, right?
I need parens not, thank you.
You can tell I'm an
old time list packer.
I really do love these things.
And is that right, John?
OK, so my apologies that
your handout is wrong.
I did not think to check
about the difference
between these things.
Nonetheless, having
done that, let's
look at what I'm going to do.
I now want to run
a loop where I need
to collect things together.
I'm going to give
a name to that.
And what you see there is
I'm going to call divisors
initially an empty tuple,
something has nothing in it.
Right here.
And then I'm going to
run through the same loop
as before, going through this
set of things, doing the check.
Now what I'd like
to do, every time
I find a divisor I'd like
to gather it together.
So I'm going to create a tuple
of one element, the value of i.
And then, ah, cool.
Here's that addition operation
that's badly overloaded.
This is why Professor
Guttag likes and I don't.
Because given that this is
a tuple and that's a tuple,
I can just add them together.
That is concatenate them, if
you like, one on the end of it.
And if I keep doing that,
when I'm done divisor
will be a collection of things.
So let me just run it.
All right.
This is what I get
for trying to --
STUDENT There
should be a comment
after the i in parentheses.
PROFESSOR ERIC
GRIMSON: Thank you.
Right there.
All right, we'll try this again.
OK.
And there are the
set of devices.
Thank you.
Who did that?
Somebody gets, no?
Yours?
Thank you.
Nice catch too by the way.
All right, so now that you
can see that I can screw up
programming, which I just did.
But we fixed it on the fly.
Thank you.
What have we done?
We've now got a way of
collecting things together,
right?
And this is the first version
of something we'd like to use.
Now that I've gotten
that bound as a name,
I could go in and
do things with that.
I could go in and say give
me the fourth divisor,
give me the second
through fifth divisor.
Again as I suggested if
I've got two integers
and I want to find
common divisors
I could take those two
lists and walk through them.
I shouldn't say list,
those two tuples,
and walk through them to find
the pieces that match up.
So I've got a way now of
gathering data together.
The last thing I want to
do is to say all right,
now that we've got this idea
of being able to collect things
into collections, we've got
the ability now to use looping
structures as we did before
but we can walk down then doing
things to them, where else might
we have this need to do things
with looping structures?
And I'm going to suggest
you've already seen it.
What's a string?
Well at some level it is an
ordered sequence of characters.
Right?
Now it is not represented
this same way.
You don't see strings
inside these open parens
and closed parens.
You don't see strings
with commas between them,
but it has the same
kind of property.
It is in ordered
sequence of characters.
We'd like to do the
same thing with strings.
That is we'd like to be able
to get pieces of them out.
We'd like to be able add them
together or concatenate them
together.
We'd like to be
able to slice them.
And in fact we can.
So strings also support things
like selection, slicing,
and a set of other
parameters, other properties.
And let's just look at that.
Again if I go back here,
let me comment this out.
Right here are a pair of strings
that I've set up, s 1 and s 2.
Let me just run these.
We can go back over here.
So I can see the value
of s 1, it's a string.
I can do things
like s 1 and s 2.
As we saw before, it simply
concatenates them together
and gives me back
a longer string.
But I can also ask
for parts of this.
So I can, for example, say
give me the first element
of string 1, s 1.
Ah, that's exactly
what we would have
thought if this was represented
as an ordered sequence
of things.
Again I should have said
first, index 0, the first one.
I can similarly
go in and say I'd
like all the things between
index 2 and index 4.
And again, remember
what that does.
Index 2 says start a 0.
1, 2.
So a, b, c.
And then it goes up to
but not including index 4
so it gets c and d
and then it stops.
I can similarly, just as
I did with the tuples,
I can ask for everything
up to some point
or I can ask for everything
starting at some point
and carrying on.
Now what you're seeing
here then is the beginning
of complex data structures.
And the nice thing
is that there's
a shared behavior there.
Just as I can have tuples as an
ordered collection of things,
strings behave as an ordered
collection of things.
So I can start thinking about
doing manipulation on strings.
I can concatenate them together,
I can find pieces inside
of them, I could actually
do things with them.
And let me show you just
a simple little example
of something I might want to do.
Suppose I take, I better
comment this one out
or it's going to spit it out.
Let me comment that out.
Suppose I take a number.
I'd like to add up all the
digits inside of the number.
I can use the tools
I've just described
in order to capture that.
So what would I want to do?
I'd like to somehow walk
down each of the digits
one at a time and add them up.
Ah, that's a looping
mechanism, right?
I need to have some way
of walking through them.
An easy way to do it
would be inside of a FOR.
And what would I like to do?
Well I need to take
that number and I'm
going to turn it into a string.
So notice what I'm
going to do right here.
I take that number and
convert it into a string.
That's an example of that type
conversion we did earlier on.
By doing that it makes it
possible for me to treat it
as an ordered sequence
of characters.
And so what's the
loop going to do?
It's going to say
FOR c, which was
my name for the
character in that string.
That means starting
at the first one,
I'm going to do something to it.
And what am I'm going to do?
I'm going to take
that character,
convert it back into an integer,
and add it into some digits.
And I've done a little
short hand here,
which is I should have
said some digits is
equal to some digits plus this.
But that little
short hand there is
doing exactly the same thing.
It is adding that
value into some digits
and putting it back or signing
it back into some digits.
And I'll walk through
that loop and when
I'm done I can print out
the total thing does.
And if I do that, I get
out what I would expect.
So what have I done?
We've now generalized
the idea of iteration
into this little pattern.
Again as I said this is my
version of it, but you can see,
every one of the examples
we've used so far
has that pattern to it.
Figure out what I'm
trying to walk through.
What's the collection of things
I'm trying to walk through.
Figure out what I want
to do at each stage.
Figure out what the end test is.
Figure out what I'm going
to do at the end of it.
I can write it explicitly.
I can write it
inside of a FOR loop.
And we've started
to add, and we'll
see a lot more of this, examples
of collections of structures
so that we don't just
have to do something that
can be easily described as
walking through a set of things
but can actually be a collection
that you walk through.
The last thing I want
to point out to you
is, I started out
with this list.
I haven't added anything
to the list, right?
I mean I've got a different
kind of looping mechanism.
I guess I should say
that's not quite true.
I've added the ability
to have more complex data
structures here.
But I dropped a hint
in the first lecture
about what you could
computer with things.
In fact if you think for
a second about that list,
you could ask what can
I compute with just
that set of constructs?
And the answer is
basically anything.
This is an example
of what is referred
to frequently as being a
Turing complete language.
That is to say with just those
set of constructs, anything
you can describe
algorithmically you can compute
with that set of constructs.
So there's good
news and bad news.
The good news is it
sounds like we're done.
Class is cancelled until final
exam because this is all you
need to know, right?
The bad news is of
course that's not true.
The real issue is to figure
out how to build constructs out
of this that tackle
particular problems,
but the fundamental
basics of computation
are just captured in
that set of mechanisms.
All right, we'll
see you next time.